hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
is it good or is it wise for a human
being to attempt or to orient their life
around making as much money or
accumulating as much wealth as possible
this was a live issue back in
Aristotle's time and we see him
addressing this in politics book 1 in
his discussion of the relationship
between the art of household management
economic hay and the art of acquisition
of wealth Primus DK and Aristotle thinks
that many people in his own time are
mistaken about this they have this
notion that unlimited accumulation of
wealth or at least getting as close to
that as possible would be a good thing
that that is what they ought to censor
and focus their life around and
prioritize their decision-making around
why is that a problem why can't we just
have unlimited acquisition or
accumulation of wealth wouldn't that
provide us with a perfect society in
some ways if we got past the fact that
taking wealth for me sometimes takes it
away from someone else Aristotle thinks
that there's something about human
nature itself that militates against
this so let's look at what he says one
of the key points that he makes is that
if we have a proper understanding of
what wealth or property really is and
what its function is to be then we're
not going to aim at unlimited wealth he
says that wealth in the truest sense and
he uses that word truest they're all
they say is goods good things that we
need or that are useful that are helpful
for our lives and for purchase
in the life of a community the exchanges
between people the the connections the
sharing and he says that there are
limits on these you don't need to have a
million dollars in the bank in order to
have a good household as a matter of
fact there's plenty of households where
right now they're in debt and maybe just
a few paychecks away from insolvency and
yet when we look at the human beings
within the household and their relations
to each other they're way happier than
many people who have tons of money in
the bank and and all sorts of prospects
for earning more and more and more so
the goods that we need to measure life
and community by the needs of those the
the usefulness of those are somewhat
limited and anybody who comes to us and
says well we can always make more and
more and more and more maybe leading us
astray according to Aristotle another
thing that he brings up is exchange and
here he talks about something that you
know we're all familiar with money but
he talked about the origin and the
purpose of money he says that in the
beginning we don't actually have money
we have just exchange or barter and
people are exchanging things back and
forth households for example exchanging
you know one agricultural product for
another manufactured product so that
they can both live well and get by and
he talks about the distinction between
proper and other uses of things so he
likes the example of shoes this is a
very common example in ancient times I
can use a shoe by actually putting the
shoe on wearing it walking around with
it protecting my feet I can also as a
householder use the shoe by putting it
on my child's foot and saying hey try
out your shoes walk around now
not gonna stub your toes now your feet
aren't going to be cracked now when you
walk on the hot gravel it's not going to
be so bad right and then there's all
sorts of other uses and when we use the
word proper here idiom is the Greek for
that this specific use the specific use
of shoes is to go on our feet it's not
to signal wealth it's not to look
fashionable it's not to take the shoe
and use it as a hammer to drive in nails
and it's not to exchange with other
people for goods and services that is
indeed a use you can make of it but
that's not its proper use and as we move
further and further away from the proper
use we move further and further away
from a sense of limits how is that the
case well I can only wear one pair of
shoes at the same time I mean I
technically I could get bigger shoes and
put shoes inside shoes or something like
that and somebody might object well what
about rain boots or galoshes yes those
are shoes that are designed to go around
other shoes granted but in general you
only wear one pair of shoes at a time
you wear them for the purpose that
you've got them for you know for example
if you're wearing soccer cleats
everywhere that's that's probably not a
good use of your soccer cleats because
they're not going to stick well to
everything or golf shoes with those
little you know pokey little pins and
things that they had for gripping the
ground golf shoes by the way we're very
good at one other thing which is not a
proper use getting yourself hit by
lightning for a long time right so the
proper in it and other uses is something
that's important to keep in mind we can
ask this about anything within the
household and think about the people who
orient their life around you know
swapping things you know buying things
so that they can sell them that is a way
of making money but Aristotle says
you're starting to go down a dangerous
path with that here he also talks about
the function of money then he says the
the real purpose of money to begin with
is to facilitate trading
because it wasn't always the case that
you could actually store up the things
that you are going to trade with
somebody else so he says they arrived at
convenient ways of exchanging things
that wouldn't lose their value like iron
or silver and they'd give you a certain
amount of it and then they started using
coins and the coin would like stamp a
certain quantity on it and you could
exchange that back and forth over time
people started thinking about money as a
primary good because you can buy other
things with it and then wealth
acquisition becomes measured by money
and then it starts to become unlimited
because if you can have a certain amount
of money for life for for the purposes
of life why not more it's not like it's
gonna go bad it's not like it's going to
rot or decompose in some way he does
bring up the fact that there can be
failures of the financial system in an
area and the money can lose its value
can become debased right but for the
most part people think of money as a
let's call it a solid investment they'd
rather have that than a whole bunch of
coconuts or butter or wool or whatever
it is that you're talking about those
things could be measured by how much can
I actually use think about groceries for
an example you know here in America we
have an incredible amount of food waste
and a lot of the food waste that we have
is not just in restaurants where it's
part of their margins it's from
consumers who buy more food than they
can actually use and then end up
throwing a good bit of it out why
because you can only keep it for so long
and we have ways around that you can it
you preserve it right you put it in the
freezer
of course then you're paying the
electric bill for the freezer and you
dry some of that or whatever it is that
you're going to do but you probably have
some food waste even if you're a very
efficient place does your money ever do
that so it seems like the money could
actually be something that you
could accumulate indefinitely without
limits
aristotle says that when the household
becomes oriented around this then you're
going to have some real problems the
other thing that he has to say about a
limited acquisition of wealth that's
particularly interesting is that it
loses sight of the fact that we should
be aiming not just at life but the good
life we should be arranging our
priorities to live the best life that we
can and many people think about this in
terms of having a ton of money in the
bank account or in income cash flow so
that they can buy whatever happens to be
their vision of the good life at that
time but Aristotle says actually that
winds up merely aiming at life not the
good life not you know living well and
here he says something really
interesting something well worth mulling
over he says that while the good life
itself is limited it has certain
boundaries life itself is unlimited so
what is he talking about there if you
conceive of life in terms of the good
life you will set down certain limits I
don't actually need this in order to be
happy but if you haven't done that sort
of thing then unlimited acquisition
could in fact seem like a quite
reasonable thing to do he says their
common ground is that the thing that
each makes of is the same they use the
same property people suppose it's the
function of household management to
increase property and their continually
under the idea it's their duty to be
safeguarding their substance or
increasing it he says
the cause of this state is that their
interests are set in life but not the
good life as the desire for life is
unlimited they also desire without limit
the
means productive of life and then he
says there's another way that people go
wrong too
they might have a different conception
of the good life they think that the
good life consists just in enjoyments
and having as much pleasure as possible
in indulging yourself as much as
possible in buying toys in having
vacations to wherever you want to go
notice there's there's really no limits
on this and as a matter of fact once you
start going down that path particularly
in our society where there's an entire
industry designed to cater to and
captivate those desires you're really at
the mercy of unlimited desire then that
other people are stoking you know if you
say well I need to have a sports boat so
I can drive around and because that's
what I'm really into well you're gonna
find more beautiful sports bolts that
you could buy if you just had a little
bit more money or a lot more money or
you might find bigger boats or you might
find fancier ones and then of course
where do you dock it do you dock it at
this marina
where all the slobs do it you know the
ordinary people or are you gonna go to
the fancy-pants place right and we could
go on and on and on with examples like
this anything you think of in terms of
bodily indulgences and pleasures can be
amped up in some way in some unlimited
way that that probably doesn't provide
genuine pleasure but does cost a good
bit more you pay a premium for those
sorts of things and in Aristotle's own
time there was already a sort of
primitive marketing and advertising
industry working to sell you those
things now it's much more sophisticated
so if we're thinking about wealth so
that we can have enjoyment that too is
unlimited but that's also not going to
make us genuinely happy Aristotle thinks
so should we aim at unlimited
acquisition of wealth Aristotle says no
and it's not just because
you know as the medievals you know
picked up on aristotle money be getting
more money is unnatural or something
like that
it also deforms and damages our own
human nature and leads us away from the
with the modes of thinking that we would
have to have in terms of genuine goods
that could lead us to the good life and
to happiness
you